Kevin one of the most important topics
right now in finance is inflation we've
seen the president United States
President Biden come out and order via
Twitter uh gas stations to lower their
prices we've seen them blame everybody
from Trump to covid to Putin uh the
whole nine yards what is going on and
are they simply as Jeff Bezos suggested
trying to do misdirection on inflation
or do they not actually understand the
basic market dynamics of what's driving
the inflation that we're facing right
now
unfortunately uh for Biden and the
administration there were some policy
mistakes made early in the Mandate over
two years ago particularly around energy
there's two pressure points that are
causing all of this political Activity
one is inflation on energy you know five
to seven dollar gasoline per gallon is
just a killer when it comes to midterm
elections there's no getting around that
problem because people see that every
time they fill up their truck or car and
then of course protein the food supply
chain in the U.S from Chicken on down is
up between 30 and 48 percent so food and
energy are very political in nature
because you're forcing families to spend
so much more of what they make on things
that they never have to worry about now
they do heating their homes and just
feeding their families and so it's very
difficult to reverse the mistakes made
in energy let's start there canceling
the Excel pipeline canceling leaseholds
on Federal Land shutting down offshore
development canceling the activity that
was going on in Alaska which was very
prolific in terms of providing gas and
oil really making it hard to figure out
carbon costs if you're if you're using
uh you know any kind of fracking service
and so all of a sudden of course we no
longer energy independent we're in a
perverse situation that even before the
Ukraine war we had Russian tankers
coming into Boston Harbor so that's
policy mistakes and you know takes time
to fix that when Biden goes over to
Saudi Arabia to get more oil from them
it won't matter to Energy prices in the
U.S because we don't have enough
Refinery capacity we just canceled
another Refinery we need three more
again bad policy now where this is going
to manifest itself in a very ugly way is
at any midterm election the incumbent
loses seats in the House
I fear for by the administration a
complete
Slaughter Fest in the midterm election
everything's going to turn it's going to
be brutal and I and I think
what do you do what can you do if you
want balance you're not going to get it
here there's going to be a lot of seats
lost in the Democratic party and in a
way they did that to themselves on bad
policy and of course they're scrambling
and anything can happen between now and
fourth quarter
but I'm not optimistic for him and you
know he he was given a mandate to solve
for the pandemic he did a reasonably
good job there but this energy policy
and what happened in inflation caught
him off guard and I'm not sure what can
be done to fix it because it's not
getting better anytime soon hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time